what's up elimination it's Evan and I'm
making my last video probably in my how
to get to 1 million subscriber series I
started this series to document my
journey to getting my first million
subscribers on YouTube and giving you
advice along the way things you can
learn things that I have experienced it
with and had some success with that you
can apply to your channel that's your
goal to build the successful YouTube
business and I am closing in on getting
a million so if I look at my social
blade let's see how we're doing we are
currently at nine sixty seven seven and
so by this time next month I will be
hitting my million subscribers which I'm
pretty pumped about and therefore will
end this series but before doing that I
have some goodies to share with you I
think what I want to share my last video
in this series I'm going to be looking
at three channels that I subscribe to
tom bill you Tim Schmoyer is video
creators and Vox and breaking down what
I like about them and where I think they
can improve and I'm also going to share
at the end a tip that i'm using to
really do effective split testing on my
videos that i haven't seen anybody else
do that's really leveraging growth for
my channel and hopefully will help you
too and then i'm gonna answer your
questions and that's it let's kick it
off so what first is tom bill you if you
haven't heard of this guy i highly
recommend checking them out if you are a
fan of my content you will probably be a
fan of his he built a billion dollar
brand called quest they had the
nutritional bars and they're delicious
but he's transitioned to inspiring and
helping entrepreneurs and wants to build
a studio bigger than disney that's
geared towards inspiring and motivating
people and i had him on a channel we
featured him a couple times what does
that believe nation again a channel you
should absolutely go check out and watch
because he's bringing some really really
great content and i'm excited to see
where he takes his channel looking at
the channel at the start he's got what a
hundred and twenty seven thousand
subscribers as a record in this video
one of the things that is great about
Tom as he's posting a lot of content so
if you look at his content here he has
three hours ago one day ago four days
ago five days ago
you know I've been pounding and pounding
and pounding on you guys importance of
doing daily videos and if you can't do
that yet
then at least make that your goal that
you want to get there tom is not quite
there you know you've posted four videos
in the past week which is better than
what most people are doing I would still
love to see Tom go Deeley if he does
that he'll get much more traction on
this channel and eventually think about
it going twice a day really you'll see
another big jump in your subscribers and
your growth but at least for now doing
four videos a week is a fantastic start
one of the things that I found confusing
about Tom when the branding was he has
impact Theory that's what the IT stands
for and you kind of see it in the
background here and you see it on the
big logos here but the difference
between what tom is about and what
impact theory is about because a lot of
the videos don't have the branding and
it's hard to know that these are his
videos so theory is part of some of his
other brands relationship theory is here
but this one doesn't have it and so just
understanding which videos are Tom's and
which aren't and being able to clearly
identify them whether you're searching
becomes really really really important
you know if I love the relationship
Theory series as an example I would know
that this is relationship siri because
most of the videos that people watch are
not going to be from going to your
channel homepage it's going to be down
the right side and so if I look down at
Tom's videos one of the things that's
really hard to tell is is this next
video that I'm going to watch one of
Tom's videos so the way to do that I've
talked about in other videos too is the
consistency so if tom is in the picture
it's great I know that that's Tom's
video but like this one I don't know
that that's Tom's video this one out of
the other Tom's
that is Tom's video some of them have
the logo some of them have Tom some of
them don't they all have different
colors different fonts different slogans
and this is a challenge if you want to
grow your YouTube channel the number one
source of traffic that you're going to
get is from related videos it's from
when somebody looks at a video like this
down here down the side that's the
number one source of traffic that you're
going to get so you need to make sure
that as people are watching your video
they know that the next video is going
to be yours and so here's an example
from one of Tom's videos and immediate
action trigger results it's great Tom's
dishing out a ton of wisdom look at
what's showing up down the side
everything that shows up down the side
from Tom's channel has the branding this
one has the branding this one has a
branding this one is a playlist that's
from him this one has a branding this
one has a branding this one has a
branding this one has a brand name and
all the other ones that are showing up
are from other people's channels lewis
howes tom bill you classics lewis howes
Chase Jarvis right so the only ones that
are showing up are the ones that are
clearly identified as Tom's videos where
it makes sense like if I'm watching this
video that I know is Tom right it's got
the impact Theory logo and then this
thing shows up on the right side I'm not
gonna click on it because I don't know
that it's Tom's video and his hardcore
fans and subscribers will watch it
because they've clicked the Balam to get
notifications and silver watch it but
that's not enough that's not how you
grow your channel right you need to be
attracting new people constantly to
build up your audience and you need to
lose the bleed so he's bleeding people
out meaning they're watching a video and
then they're not gonna go see his other
videos because they don't know that
they're his right I'm watching this
video I'm gonna click on the ones that I
know are Tom's and the other ones that
are Tom's it still may be great aren't
showing up because the brainian is
inconsistent and so I'd be really
looking hard at having a consistent
brand across whether it's Tom in the
picture having him in it is great
whether it's the logo somewhere
the recent relationship theory where's
that one if I go back to his main page
here this right like I'm assuming that's
Tom but I I don't know that that's Tom
right I only think that that's Tom
because I'm on Tom's channel but I might
just saw that down the side I wouldn't
recognize Tom you want pictures where
it's easy that's him that's him right
that's him that's him that's him I can
easily see it ain't I be looking at
puttin the logo on every single video
and this is where the branding becomes a
little confusing is it impact Theory is
it tom bill you he has a bunch of sub
brands right you see his name on this
one then he has after impact and so it's
just hard to track from one video to the
next if it's going to be his content and
that's why he's losing a ton of views
down this related sidebar and the people
are really gonna be clicking on the one
in that series so Tom if you're watching
put the branding make it consistent
another quick example you look at this
one so
you know here he has all caps and
thereon in italics and whatever font
that is here it's all taxed but it's all
caps but it's yellow here is using red
here it's using orange here's a
challenge you look at the video like
this look at this thumbnail right you
see Lois how's the definition of a real
man
great this matches none of his other
videos apart from the fact that there's
a big face and some text here's another
channel that is in our space that is
related that has some interesting videos
it's motivational and what do you see
you see a big face and you see yellow
and white text right big face yellow and
white text if I saw this in my sidebar
right I'm watching the video I'm
watching a video and I see that
thumbnail I see this thumbnail I'm gonna
think it's not Tom's channel it's the
bean spired channel that's the challenge
now maybe I love the be inspired channel
he's doing it intentionally to try to
seep some of their traffic over to his
but I don't think this is Tom's channel
sure it says Tom bill you here but I'm
not gonna read that most people don't
read that they barely read the title
they're looking at the thumbnail first
and so it has to be clearly identified
that this video that I'm watching is Tom
and I know which ones just down the side
is Tom's right away so that consistent
branding will make a huge huge huge huge
huge impact and then figuring out how to
show your sub brains so relation Theory
has its own logo I would still have the
impact theory or the Tom will you logo
somewhere that's the decision tom has to
make what's the core brand what's the
big brand and whether the sub brands
underneath and showing each one on each
video next one thing I wanna look at
I've hated a lot on short videos in a
bunch of my videos in this series just
for the reason that YouTube doesn't like
short videos you have to have just such
an insanely great short video and by
short I'm talking like five minutes on
there six minutes on there you want to
be in the 10 to 12 minute content range
at least for your videos if you want to
win in this current evolution of
YouTube's algorithm and so tom has a
bunch of these short motivational one so
he's got this one think different invest
in yourself go big these are what three
minutes two 4323 what else
2:11 I clicked on a few of them and one
it's it's hard because again they're not
branded him you can't tell that that's
you video but to they're so short and so
look what happens if I click on these
videos invest in yourself 240 do
something today 227 focus your thoughts
210 okay one of the most important
things that you want to pay attention to
is you're building your channel out is
for each individual series that you're
doing you look at are they generating
traffic and are they generating
subscribers for your video so as Tom's
going through this channel he's got a
whole bunch of these different series
that John is here you see impact codes
full episodes of impact Theory
relationship theory asked on Bill you
I've been looking through each of these
series take the last ten of them and
then go look at the stats to see how
they're doing reason being this series
here this impact quotes is not really
serving Tom that well luckily because
they're short and likely because the
brand name is so poor look invest in
yourself three subscriptions driven
twenty days watch time do something
today two subscriptions driven twenty
three days watch time focus your
thoughts one subscription driven sixteen
days watch time and it may be appealing
to say well look it's getting thirteen
thousand views the views don't matter
it's such a tiny video it's not leaving
to new people the only people watching
this are Khatami's current subscriber
base which is great to support them but
if a video does not do well in YouTube's
eyes if this video comes out has poor
watch time with sixteen days one
subscription driven what's gonna happen
is YouTube will not promote that video
widely it'll go to your hardcore
audience but nobody else is going to see
it that becomes a real problem if you
want to grow a brand right to help Tom
get to the point where his channel is
bigger his studio is bigger than Disney
YouTube can be a big role in that and
you need to be making content that
people are paying attention to and so
what I be looking at this series this
series is not working for Tom right now
it's not generating watch time it's not
draining subscribers for his channel
this series is failing so how do we fix
it right this series is not working we
can fix the branding right we can make
them longer or maybe we cut them unless
a series of serve you know strategic
advantage unless as an example you have
a sales video if Tom's coming up with
some new content or if he's promoting an
event or he's launching his first
eCourse whatever it is that he's trying
to promote you expect poor watch time
you expect not to gain subscribers from
it but unless that video serves a
strategic advantage you're cutting that
series or you're really trying to work
to improve it so I've been looking
through each of these series and you
find that a good chunk of them are
generating good subscribers and good
views and good watch time and a good
chunk of them aren't and so something
like this I would cut or massively
retool so that is actually helping me
grow my channel because it's only going
to the hardcore subscribers youtube is
downgrading the next video that comes
out because these videos don't perform
well but net-like that's just some
strategies Tom's content is awesome it's
fire I highly recommend you guys
checking it out and if he if he takes
these approaches he'll be out on million
subscribers in no time as well and I
look forward to it because I think we
need more quality content in the
entrepreneur space okay let's move on
let's go to Tim Schmoyer Channel so Tim
Schmoyer runs a great channel called
video creators they helped me a ton when
I was first starting my youtube channel
giving me advice on how to build and
grow my channel and so super
appreciative the Tim for all of his help
and advice his videos are awesome let's
look at the difference here now Tim on
the frequency side could be posted a
little bit more right he used to be I
think three times a week and it looks
like he's still around that three hours
ago five days ago one week ago so two in
that week two in that week two in that
week so he's pretty consistent to a week
and again if Tim really wants to explode
this channel I'd be saying he needs to
go daily find a way to do it whether
you're mashing up old content whether
you're doing more off-the-cuff stuff
just finding ways to produce quality
content on a daily basis building up
your team bringing on guests whatever it
is so that you can drive growth faster
but the thing that I love about Tim is
look at his thumbnails Tim always has
pretty interesting thumbnails right that
makes me want to watch I'm always
curious by the design of Tim some nails
he always has a face so he's in it so
like unlike Tom we're in a lot of his
videos he's in it but a lot of them he's
not tim is in pretty much every single
video thumbnail so it's easy for me to
recognize that this is his video there's
always some interesting art work going
on we have money we have exit signs we
have views and
especially when it's bigger it looks it
looks really clean so this is really
important having captivating thumbnails
that people want to click on one of the
things that I noticed he changed
recently every video used to have this
videocreatorstv branding down the side
so it's easy to tell if that's a Tim
Schmoyer video just like we were talking
about impact Theory you see the logo
he's recently switched it to this so it
still has the the video and now it has
this little red line down here this is
not as visible and what I recommend is
making sure that this part of the video
is always super clear so you can see
like he's done a little bit of black
around here a little shadowing to make
it stand out a little bit here's a
little bit more shadowing compared to
the rest of the video but it's not as
recognizable you need more contrast
either make this red bigger make that
black bigger put something inside the
video camera or something so that that
pops out a little bit more it's a great
scene Tim on the thumbnail of every
video but that branding does not shout
out as being super noticeable especially
when it's smaller because again this is
not the actual size you're seeing it at
this is the size right that's the size
so it's going to be even smaller and yes
he's in the picture of all of them but
you want to have consistent branding
that is easy to see this I don't know
why he dropped it maybe was too big and
maybe was taking up too much of the
space but anytime I saw a left thumbnail
you know it's easy to know that this is
tim schmoyer video and I need to pay
attention again what you want to worry
about is after they finished watching
one video you want them to watch another
and another and another and another and
know that it's yours finally I want to
take a quick look at Vox box is another
channel subscribe to they have over
three million subscribers they post
pretty frequently
one day four day six days one one week
one week one week one week so like here
they post six in a week so four to six
per week again if they could move daily
it'd be amazing to grow even faster than
they are one of the things I wanted to
highlight here though is their branding
is on every video so if you look it says
Vox box box
Vox borders Vox Vox Pop earworm Vox box
Fox they are personally driven a little
bit this is one of their hosts but their
hosts aren't in most of the videos they
try to use something that people over
isn't it with so you know you see you
see Trump you know who he is you know
it's about they try to have captivating
thumbnails that make it interesting for
but click on 2 as opposed to making the
personality-driven and so again if this
this didn't have Vox and I just finished
this video
I wouldn't know that this is a box video
and so I may not click on it even though
I love Vox content and so having that
there the thumbnail makes me want to
click on it more what's interesting here
is what they did with their sub series
so just like we're talking about Tom the
backup the Tom's Channel here he has all
these different series right whatever
this one is after impact the AMA Series
impact Theory series got a whole bunch
but the branding isn't consistent one of
the things that Fox does is they have
their logo and then they have the series
logo with it now I think the logos a
little bit too small it's hard to see
that Vox
and again remember that this is going to
be even smaller on this thumbnails that
show up down the side here it's even
harder it's yellow it's voxpop
it's not the same font they're same
uppercase and then into the lowercase
I'd have a hard time knowing that that
is a Vox video unless I really
understood them and I love the earworm
series or I love the the border series
here again it's hard to read that that
says Vox Pop you have to really really
pay attention and so I love the fact
that they're trying to mix the branding
so they have a main brain which is Vox
and then they're showing the sub series
as well I would just say to make the
main branding a little bit bigger so you
can see what it's all about as an
example of their evolution this is what
borders looks like now this is what it
used to look like
so borders as personality-driven is this
guy is in all the borders videos and it
used to show him and then what he was
talking about in the videos and it says
box borders now they took him out and
they just show a big thumbnail here's
another one they took him out borders
and they show a big thumbnail where they
used to have him on all the thumbnails
and so it's interesting like maybe him
being on the thumbnail people didn't
resonate with as much and this is one of
the things that you want to keep testing
you test the thumbnails you test the
titles you test you test you test and
see what is resonating and what is not
for anybody who's running multiple
series on the same Channel I highly
recommend that you visually show on the
series on the thumbnail that this is
from your channel so you don't lose
viewers let me show you mine this is one
of the ways that I've done it
a bunch of different series right I have
the top ten series I have the ants
bestest series I have the unlock and
Lily series I have my vlog you know I
have a whole bunch of different series
pretty much all of them have the
consistent airplane branding right
unless it's a live stream like this one
everything else has at least the
airplane some of them have a secondary
logo and that represents their series so
the coffee cup is an espresso and you'll
see that here and you'll see that here
and you'll see that here you know the
trees is believe life and the ten is the
top ten if the volume - you see a little
- but top 10 top 10 top 10 and espresso
one rule you know we have a series logo
as well as the company logo in general
it's pretty easy to see that these are
my videos we have a consistent font same
color same orange same white usually a
picture on the side we shake it up a
little bit you know this is this is the
biggest departure from our usual
branding is the ain't vibe series
because it's also the biggest departure
from our typical content where this is
music its productivity music to help you
in your business but it's still our
color
it's still our font it's still our
airplane and it's still a customized
logo for that series something like this
is another example that's a little
different but still is not that far off
from what we're typically dealing with a
bunch of faces a big font white orange
it doesn't have the secondary font
because this is a test video it's not
part of a series yet something that
we're thinking about adding in and so
one of the reasons why I get so much
views and so many subscribers to my
channel
apart from posting lots of content right
like we did three videos in the past 19
hours and then three videos a day before
right and then so every day we're
posting pretty much three videos that
helps but it's also easy for people to
know that once they watch this video
that this is also my video and this is
also my video and this is also my video
and this is also my video people go from
one to the next to the next to the next
and next and so I don't lose as many
people as other channels will so that's
my quick suggestions I want to give you
a bonus tip that I've never talked about
on this channel and haven't really
shared with anybody else yet that's
really helping me split test my videos
and I think it'd be super valuable for
you since this is my last video in this
series
this is it split-testing so last month I
talked about split testing I talked
about two buddy a great tool to be able
to use to split test your thumbnails and
your titles to see which format works
better one of the things I'm
experimenting with though is how can we
split test the actual format of the
video so you guys may have noticed my
top 10 we change the formatting we
change the template the sidebar used to
be white and now it's black and it has a
bunch of motion on it and so we're
testing like does that work does that
work or not and one of the best ways to
do it is to create three or multiple
unlisted videos and then run ads against
them to compare watch time so here's
what I did we made three different
versions of simon Sinek so one of them
would be the white background that's
what we had typically that's what most
of our historical top tens look like one
of them was a black background with the
countdown with a little video inside it
of what's coming up next and one of them
was the black background with a still
picture instead of the video picture
we're basically testing the formatting
like the people like the black
background the people like the variety
and the change you know people want it
simple and clean it's hard to guess and
it's hard to make decisions just based
off of comments because a lot of times
you're gonna vocal minority people who
say they love something or they hate
something but it doesn't reflect what
people actually like and so what I did
was I ran an ad campaign against all
three videos and I spent money to drive
what 60,000 views plus those three
videos and see how they did and what
ended up working out was the black side
background this video black side
background with a still picture
performed the best and so that's gonna
be our new template going forward until
we find a better one that outperforms
they all have about the same traffic
22,000 views 21 and a half 21,000 views
and then looking at the watch time so
I'm just basically seeing so basically
looking at seeing when I send people to
this video how long are they staying and
what I divided them into was hours so
two hundred and thirty seven thousand
minutes is how many watch hours you
can't just look at data here this is
where a lot of people make a mistake you
don't have enough data to make a
decision you can't just say well this
perform better so I'm gonna go with this
one the data has to be statistically
significant so this is a free tool
here off KISSmetrics if you look up
KISSmetrics and a be significance test
what it allows you to do is put in your
two metrics so this is how many visitors
we have and this is a number of watch
hours same thing visitors and watch
hours on the two variations and it'll
say that one performed better than the
other it'll calculate conversion rate
but then this is what you want to pay
attention to version a converted by
percent better than variation B we're
99% certain that the changes in
variation a will improve your conversion
rate your a B test here is statistically
significant now it's only 5% better
right five percent is not a huge amount
which is why I had to spend so much to
get lots of views if this was a big
difference I might only have to have
five thousand views instead of twenty
two thousand views on each video but you
need to make sure that you have the
right data because as an example this
video which was second best was leaving
at the beginning this was in the first
test the best video but there wasn't
enough data to say that it was distantly
significant and so we had to keep
running it and now we found out that oh
this is the best one and it's five
percent better
I mean it's 99% certain the test is
statistically significant so five
percent may not seem a lot but it is did
you do five percent across all your
videos that makes a huge difference if I
get five percent more subscribers off of
a million that makes a big difference
you know if I'm getting how many more
you know if I'm getting what is this
fifteen thousand more watch minutes
because of just changing the template
that's that's a difference and now this
becomes my new standard and then I want
to try to beat that and try to beat that
and so what the public sees what you
guys see a subscribers is always the
best version the winning version and
then I run an ad campaign against
unlisted videos that nobody sees to see
which one generates the most watch time
so we can pick those templates and we're
always trying to beat our best template
to get the best results YouTube
unfortunately doesn't provide great ways
to split test results and so that's why
you have to rely on something like tube
buddy to be able to test your thumbnails
and test your titles and again you know
one of my biggest beefs with two buddy
is they don't tell you if the data is
sadistically significant like one might
get a hundred views the other might get
one hundred and three
and they'll say virgin a is better but
maybe didn't get enough traffic to
actually make a difference right and you
can be picking the wrong thing right the
data lies when it's small right if you
only flip the coin once you say it's
heads its heads heads is the winner but
really it's just a 50/50 so you have to
make sure that you're using the right
tools and that you're testing for
significance and you can use that
KISSmetrics tool so you can use to buddy
to find your titles and thumbnails and
you can use AdWords to run campaigns
against unlisted videos to then see
which template you use is having a
better result
that's my suggestions for this month for
the series I want to get to your
questions let's see what you guys asked
from the last video first up value
tainment evan thanks for the feedback
extremely helpful looking forward to
seeing you cross one million so last
month i featured value tainment and it's
great it's great that he loved the
comment patrick's an awesome
entrepreneur he put his channel on hold
hopefully as temporary because Patrick's
got an amazing channel tons of content
to help entrepreneurs and they'd be sad
to see value tainment go away and you
know I want to see more entrepreneur
content and it just helps everybody get
better so hopefully Patrick will be back
go to pass this channel value tainment
leave a comment say Patrick come back we
need you we love you we want your
content but it's great that he'd love to
comment here what else we have the habit
guy a couple of questions first off how
are you getting nine million views a
month I'm gently interested because when
I look at your channel most your videos
look like the average between five and
seven thousand and the bigger question
you gave advice on how to get your
videos notice in suggesting videos but
how do you actually position them on
suggested videos that's the downfall I'm
having thanks mate you're great like
anything else is an 8020 rule if you
look at your content you'll find that
most of your subscribers and most of
your views come from a select few videos
so while most of my videos might have
whatever a thousand views on them I have
that 20% or even look at YouTube it's
really like 5% or 2% of videos that just
really crush it and outperform and so
that's what you're always trying to
build right that's what you're always
trying to get to is what you're always
trying to create but you don't know
which one is necessarily going to take
off and hit it and crush it and hit a
homerun for you and
that's how I'm able to do it you know I
think if you look at if you just look at
views per video you looking at the wrong
metric if you are so attached and this
is something that I debate with with
fellow youtubers they're so concerned
about how many views they get per video
it's the wrong metric if we go back to
Tom's channel look at his short
motivational two-minute clips they may
get more views than his other videos but
it's the wrong metric to follow because
they're not leading to watch time and
they're not lead to subscribers for his
channel which ultimately he wants to
make an impact and the impact doesn't
come from the views that comes from be
able to keep people on the channel
consuming your message and then going
off and making an impact in their lives
so looking at views per video is the
wrong metric pay attention to watch time
pay attention subscribers because that's
what YouTube cares about YouTube cares
about watch time so pay attention to
that if that changes if it goes to
something else then switch but right now
unless you want to pay attention to you
and that's how I do it in terms of
getting your videos on suggested it's
what I talked a lot about in this video
you want to make it easy for somebody to
go from one of your videos to another
video to another video and so all of
that is done via YouTube's algorithm
right there's nobody manually looking at
it and say oh this looks that looks like
another to have a guy's channel and so
I'm gonna I'm gonna show that there you
can't choose what's there it's from the
algorithm and the algorithm is based on
what people's viewing habits are and so
if somebody is historically watching
your kind of content and they're
circling watching those kinds of topics
then it'll show up and YouTube's always
running his little test and so they'll
show another video that may be a little
bit off-topic and they see does this
person click-through and if they do then
they'll keep showing more of those
videos and if they don't then they'll
drop it from the algorithm and this is
what happens so as an example to go back
to Tom's channel and we look at that
that short clip that has go big or dream
or whatever when it first comes out on a
select few of Tom's subscribers it'll
show that video down the right side
nobody's gonna click on it because they
don't know that that's Tom's video and
then that video is going to get down
ranked they're not gonna show it anymore
because YouTube knows nobody who watches
this video then wants to go off and
watch that select video right so it's
constantly these tests and so you want
to make it as easy as possible for the
viewer to finish one of your videos and
then want the
to the next so consistent branding great
thumbnails good titles and again easy to
know that this coming video the next one
up is yours
next sim LAN this month 1 million
subscribers thank you for the love
probably not we're probably looking
early December
my goal was end of the year so we beat
that I'm still thinking about the next
goal it's gonna be 10 but it's far away
so I got a I got a ramped up the 10
million a lot faster than what my
current growth rate is at which is
exciting and challenging at the same
time what else
Anthony lovelies break down to the
bigger channels very helpful thanks Evan
I'm glad you appreciated Anthony it's a
little sad that this is the end of the
series you know it's good and that
listen this series takes me a lot of
time to do is its of all my series the
most that I personally invest into a
video and that's a lot of free time that
now I have to build my channel do other
things for you guys and honestly if I
look at the advice I gave the Tom pay
attention to each series and are they
helping you grow is it leading to watch
time and subscribers for you this series
is just ok it's just ok compared to my
other videos this is not one of my best
performing series I do it for the love
but ending it will not hurt my channel
if I replace it with something else
it'll actually help grow my channel and
so yes you do things out of a hobby yes
you do things out of love but the love
has to match up with what the audience
wants as well and so it's sad to lose
the series but I've lost a lot of series
and I'm doing it because I'm gonna
replace with something better the ROI
isn't worth that compared to the other
things that I'm working on for them Joe
uh Victor that Rosa I hope I pronounced
that ok if there were subtitles in other
languages your videos would be able to
reach more people and can and
consequently get more subscribers that's
an interesting test maybe the answer is
maybe I for the longest time had English
subtitles on my videos I use a service
called Rev comm they charge one dollar
per minute to do English subtitles and
they uploaded automatically to the
videos so there's no work for you apart
from ordering the transcript it wasn't
working I couldn't prove an ROI it's the
best practice if you look at most
YouTube experts they'll tell you you
need to put
captions and transcribe your videos I
couldn't prove it I couldn't prove the
ROI now it's not a ton of money that was
going out but still yeah you know you're
investing money is something you want to
prove the ROI I did multiple tests to
take some of my videos and translate
them into different languages and I took
the popular ones I took the ones I felt
we would play well to a certain
demographic and I could not prove the
ROI long story short I just could not
prove the ROI maybe I was doing
something wrong maybe it works well for
other people just not for me
but I could not prove the ROI to make it
worthwhile and so I haven't done it and
I think it's important for for your
channel and for your business to test
your tests in your testing your tests
I'm testing my thumbnails you guys may
love them you may hate them I'm going
with the winners I'm testing my
templates and my sidebars you may love
them you may hate them I will lose some
people because of the test and I'll gain
some other people because of the test
but net I win because you're picking the
ones that have the best results and so I
couldn't justify the expense of
transcribing into English and then
translating into an another language
I couldn't justify either expenses so
I'm not doing it and I use those
resources to make better videos and more
videos for you guys now that doesn't
mean the test ends maybe YouTube changes
our algorithm maybe multi-language is
more important maybe transcriptions
really become the thing and I go back to
it just because you did the test as I
mean you can't do another one in the
future but at least for now from my data
from my experience transcriptions and
translations are not worth it that kind
of sucks next Eddie what would be your
advice for all the YouTube competitors I
know all YouTube competition has their
own problems who YouTube out competes on
but apart from that what else could
these competitors do to out-compete
YouTube its services in its community
why would I jump to you to another
cervicals YouTube because they're doing
something that's better
or because they have a big community
that I can jump on to just today as an
example I was looking to get Lilly more
experience in jumping in on
conversations with people and it made me
think back to blab if you guys were ever
involved in blab you could join in on
hangouts and be a part of conversations
and I was looking for a competitor
because blob shut down and there was
nothing and so there was no solution
there's no answer like here's a problem
nobody solved it so if somebody could
come in and solve that problem for all
the people who want to complain about
YouTube there's no better place to be in
my view if you want content that lives
forever I think if you're posting videos
of Facebook it's you get a quick
immediate hit it can convert potentially
but I want content that's gonna last you
know my views my videos I've made 5,000
plus of them in 10 years hopefully
people start watching them right
I still get views on my videos from 6
years ago now it doesn't happen in the
facebook environment and so it's not
interesting for me but if that changed
and YouTube became just short-term stuff
and Facebook or some other new app came
out that allowed me to have my content
live forever and there was an audience I
would go I'm not attached to YouTube I
mean I love you too I love all you guys
but if you guys are all somewhere else
I'm not gonna stick on YouTube I'll go
there so you need to have better
features and you need to have a
community and right now nobody's even
close in my opinion so I'm not even
close to switching Amanda make the
channel growth the goal love this video
thanks to the tips yeah I think it's
important that you have a goal for your
channel I think it has to support your
business and your mission and what
you're trying to do I think every video
back to looking at Tom's channel every
video needs to support the growth of
your channel or needs to have another
strategic goal so for my channel my life
with Evans series as an example is my
vlog series it's my least performing
series it's the worst performing series
on my channel people don't want to see
me vlog you guys you could kill me you
want to see my life so sad but that's ok
I'm ok with be my least my worst
performing series one for personal
reasons like I have this great archive
of my life that I can look back on and I
actually have a TV in my kitchen that
plays the videos from life with Evan
randomly and so I'm in the kitchen and
then this video from three years ago
shows up like oh yeah we did that it's
like a picture frame that's constantly
bringing back old memories and - because
the people who do watch it are really
hardcore supporters I think you need to
have a certain percentage I say around
10% of your content
be personal be about you so that the
people who really love you can learn
more about you and and the people who
are starting to like you can now
actually love you and really appreciate
your content because at the end of the
day the people who are gonna buy from
you the people you're gonna have take
action to whatever it is that you want
them to do are gonna meet your hardcore
fans you know I'm coming to my new book
right I just submitted it today although
when this goes live it won't be today
but I submitted my book today to Amazon
it's the top ten with success
different cover than this who's gonna
buy it the people who are gonna buy it
are not the casual yeah I watched one
video and I learned something from it
and I every month I come in it's not
gonna be that person for the most part
it's gonna be the people who are
hardcore who love my content who are
obsessed with it who evidence part of
their daily routine and the life with
Evan vlog series brings us closer
together it's it's shocking how much
people feel they know me and like me and
trust me and I have no idea who you are
have no idea who they are when I'm
meeting them but they feel like they
know me I have a guy come and clean my
my air filter today it's like I'm a fan
of your channel man that's like oh
that's great they'll clean my hair
filter so having having a certain
percentage of your content be personal I
think is important because those would
be the people who you make super fans
and they'll take the action you want
them to take but otherwise if a series
isn't doing well cut it like this series
this series is not one of my best
performing series it takes up a lot of
time so we're gonna cut it we hit our
goal we're gonna hit a million unless it
just takes me another six months and hit
a million for some reason that would be
very sad then this series is gone and
I'm gonna replace it with something else
that I can get higher leverage out of
right this doesn't serve a huge need or
strategic advantage for me compared to
doing other other forms of content so it
has to serve every series has to serve
the growth of your channel or another
strategic advantage like you're selling
the course like you're getting people in
your newsletter like you get in to take
action somehow one of those two there
has to be a reason for this video to
exist otherwise kill it try to your
trade thanks for answering my questions
about SEO and posting on videos YouTube
versus Facebook I have a follow-up you
mention this better to convert within a
platform that your
and that you wouldn't try to convert a
YouTube audience into being subscriber
on a website I'm a little confused by
what you're then trying to convert on
YouTube are you talking about converting
the sale or something on YouTube
converting people in subscribers on your
channel or something else ultimately
with YouTube we're building a brand
right and we're trying to get people to
do something in their life right we're
getting them to buy a product and take
action and that may be moving people to
a website to sign up for your course or
sending out a message to meet me up in
Atlanta or whatever it is my point in
making that comment was if your goal is
to grow the YouTube channel on YouTube
as your platform the best way to do it
is within YouTube not Facebook if your
if your goal is to grow on Facebook use
Facebook don't use YouTube try to grow
Facebook don't use Facebook they try to
grow YouTube right yes I promote my
videos and all my platforms whenever a
new video comes alive YouTube's my main
source if I look at my social media
presence is YouTube then Facebook and
then Twitter and then Instagram when I
launch a video goes everywhere but the
best leverage that I get is for a
YouTube video is on YouTube I'll post a
link on Facebook I'll post a link on
Twitter and it sends some people but the
most leverage I get is from YouTube and
if you look at your own stats go to your
analytics go to your like some news
channel look at where your views are
coming from it's coming from related
search down the right side and it's
coming from homepage it's coming from
subscriptions you might get some from
search and then usually fourth or fifth
or six is gonna be external websites
that's Facebook that's Twitter that's
your newsletter that's everything else
that you're sending people to now if
you're super-tiny channel your numbers
might be a little skewed but if you look
at all the big channels that's where it
comes from the number one source of
traffic for big channels which I want
you guys to get to because if you if you
tweak the algorithm like if you've
tweaked your videos to fit the algorithm
you win you start getting tons more
traffic and views and subscribers coming
in to help you achieve your goals the
point of that comment was don't try to
go to Facebook or to YouTube or to
tumblr to any other website to try to
drive traffic to your YouTube videos
spend that time on YouTube if you want
to convert people to subscribers on
YouTube your best source is people from
YouTube by optimizing for the sidebar
not trying to
some people coming outside next
Alexander does he play League of Legends
by looking at his subscription lol I was
first curious during his book video when
he called his dog team oh yes I play
League of Legends not a ton I am
bronze I've been silver I play Teemo I'm
a Teemo main with the Heimerdinger back
up when I can't get them I usually get
S's in my game but yeah I like I like
League of Legends we'll see how the new
patch comes out I played on my spare
time I usually play when I can't sleep
this is this is what I do at night if
I'm thinking about an idea I've got this
great idea or I'm thinking about how to
grow my channel or I'm thinking about
TDs I'm thinking about something I can't
sleep and I'm tossing and turning I
wrote down my ideas but I still can't
sleep I get up I play a game of League
and I'm so focused on that game that I
forget about whatever I was thinking
about before and then the game is over
and then I don't think about anymore
I don't I don't get tilted I don't get
stressed out about the game it just
allows me to forget about what I was
thinking about the game is over I'm in
it I'm so focused on playing that I lose
focus of everything else and then once
the game is done my brain is empty I can
relax and I can go to sleep so that's
that's typically if you're if you're
playing with me you can look me up the
leave team on the North American server
that's usually at night sometimes other
times when I'm trying to get distracted
65 drums is my absolute favorite series
you have you're the only guy
consistently here promoting the daily
upload strategy I'm working on it
currently of 15 videos a month I love
this your favorite series I'm sorry that
that it's gonna disappear after this one
a lot of people talk about going daily
or at least be more consistent with the
content you know I think it's hard for a
lot of the YouTube consultants and
experts to really push going daily one
because they're not doing it themselves
you know if you look back on Tim's
channel he's doing like a couple of week
so it's hard for him to say go daily and
a lot of the people who they work with
aren't going daily too so they may not
have the data right if Tim's working
with other YouTube clients and they're
not going day daily he may not have the
data to say like here's what really
happens everything I talk about is based
off of my own data now I don't have
clients I don't
I'm not looking at lots of different
youtubers sometimes the youtubers that I
connect with will compare kind of high
level data but I share with you what's
working for me
and so I know that going daily really
impacted my channel more than almost
anything else and then going twice a day
again twice a day go twice a day it'll
make a huge impact from once twice a day
is a huge jump and again from two to
three a day not that big a jump and so
that's where I'm at I meant I meant
three a day and so I try to make sure
the things that I have data on that I
know that work even if it goes against
traditional wisdom like get your videos
captioned and get your videos translated
into different languages I tried it
doesn't work for me it may work for you
you could try it doesn't work for me so
there are people talking about it I just
don't think it's it's anywhere close to
industry standard yet and this is great
like this is your opportunity people are
not doing this yet they will and when
the big companies come in and they start
going daily you're gonna get crushed so
this is your chance now you have this
window now where nobody is going daily
this is how you can win with inferior
content you are not as good but you can
still do better than the people who are
better than you because you understand
the algorithm better and then by going
daily you'll get better like you have to
get better if you're making a video
every day your skills will get better
your comfort level will get better your
confidence will get better and you'll
make better better videos write the
quantity leads to the quality and so
anybody who's watching this who wants to
build a YouTube channel you have such an
amazing time ahead of you now before
people really get into it that if you
can find a way to go daily or at least
up your content and make that your goal
within the next year to go daily that's
a minimum guys like I I want you guys
going twice a day and when I say that
people freaked out because there any
once a day is is just too crazy just
people have people have low standards to
what they expected themselves they feel
like they can only do so much and
they're thinking in a really small way
like you're not gonna be able to do
everything yourself the whole time you
have to figure out ways to build your
business bring on a team and take it
seriously this is not a solo thing
forever you want to have an impact you
got to build a team you got to build
things bigger I make three videos a day
because I have eight people who work on
my
but when I started I had one person me
that's it I never invested anything I
didn't invest a single cent into my
YouTube channel that I wasn't already
making back I invested my time and
energy my hustle into my channel I
started making some money I invested
that back into the business growth but
if you have a goal to do something then
you start working towards it if you just
see it as impossible I can never make a
video a day I can never make two videos
a day you're crazy well then you'll
never get there
congratulations because you don't
believe you can what if you said that as
your goal even if you can't do it today
right you could start with a 30-day
challenge so with a 30-day challenge
I'll make one video a day for 30 days
just do that just prove yourself that
you can do it start getting some results
so it seems from traffic and then expand
bring them a team you can part time
build this thing up if you want to take
it seriously you want have an impact
that's what you got to do my Mohammed my
question is when is the perfect time to
upload videos I mean in the morning
evening how do you know in perfect time
is I don't pay a whole lot of attention
to that to be honest I think mostly
because my traffic is all over the place
it's it's mostly us but with you know
three different times or four different
times on three different times those how
many times well it's four different
times of [ __ ] on my us geography so you
know I put my in spresso videos out
first idea was that is a shot of
espresso in the morning it's a morning
video and that comes out I think it's
7:00 a.m. Eastern so that's coming out
at 4:00 a.m. on the west coast so I
don't speak up but for you I'm watching
it there are some videos you can watch
some people who've done analytics on it
tubular lab to think has a tool that
tells you the time of day that your
videos are most popular I haven't played
with it I don't know I feel it's low
leverage I might be it just might be a
blind spot for me I haven't I don't have
any data to tell you I haven't done any
experiments beyond just I try to post at
different times based on East Coast so
answer presses in the morning my next
video is around lunchtime and then the
last video is at 8 o'clock so it's
typically our schedule I think it's 7
a.m. noon 8 p.m. Eastern yeah maybe
there's leverage and switching that up
it's like how do you test that there's
no good way to test it there's no good
way to split test it so lets robably I
haven't done it and it feels the
leverage but again could be a blind spot
for me
go and try it Alexandra it would be
amazing if we got to know the whole
believe team when you're hitting million
subscribers yeah I still don't really
have my plan for what's gonna happen in
a million and it's pretty close
mostly because I don't really want to do
anything this that's that's the honest
answer I don't want to do anything and
so I haven't planned anything I don't
really enjoy celebrating so I don't know
it's a good ping I got to figure
something out yeah thank you thank you
for the kick to the but we'll see if you
look at within thank you so much so many
great tips in one video I hope believe
team which is 2 million soon two million
is great ten millions better that's the
next goal
next up good mandir i watched your video
evan until your QA i was amazed to see
how clear the different results to work
concerning comparisons with different
variations you used by choosing a better
option three times concerning us finally
faced in place of text and quote a
subject one can easily realize how you
can easily increase reactions by those
of watching videos yeah that's I mean
SAT of sweat testing so what testing is
common in marketing so testing is in
every traditional industry it's just not
not super common in YouTube yet it's
because it's such a new industry the
idea of not split testing is crazy like
Amazon all these become but they split
test everything every little my new shed
their split testing I mean it's harder
because youtube doesn't give you the
tools to be able to do it but most
people aren't even thinking about it and
again gives you an advantage this last
split test that I showed you in this
video it's a five percent increase
great like if you keep making five
percent increases every time that's a
small that's a small improvement for me
but if I then make another get another
tweak and you look back and like every
week every month you may get a new five
percent increase that's huge growth huge
growth because you're testing and other
people aren't and so you need to always
you're running lots and lots of lots of
tests not all them work out you know be
prepared that's fine
like most most things probably won't
work out and you get hit with a winner
you know the winner of this last test
surprised my team they weren't expecting
not to be the winner but it's the winner
and it's 5% better 99% certain sits it's
at least significant so that's what
we're running with and then we're gonna
try to beat that and with something else
right that constant improvement makes a
big difference
Maddie waters new friendly rival
kruseman command maybe Charlie's a great
guy I spoke to him last week he's he's
having some awesome chat
growth he's planning his next phase
maybe it could be a new new rival we'll
see Gary bees also picking up he's still
behind me but but he's picking up steam
so he might pass me again and I have a
new goal to the chase we'll see I should
still beat him to a million but yeah
we'll see we'll see I'm still I'm
getting more and more excited about the
10 million goal and I got to think what
do I need to change in my current
process because I am oh you hit 10
million eventually doing what I'm doing
but I need to make some radical changes
to hit 10 million faster makes you think
on a bigger level so stay tuned if you
have if you have ideas or thoughts or
suggestions for me hitting 10 million
leave those below I'm super curious
we're gonna end it there thank you guys
I have to go pick up Nina from the
subway and do husbandly things I
appreciate the support and the love and
it was it was a really fun journey
making this series for you guys I got to
share some of the knowledge that I
normally only share to big youtubers
one-on-one when I'm meeting with them
and so it was great to be able to bring
that to you hopefully you can use it
look back on the other videos all that
advice is still relevant use that to
grow your channel use that to spread a
message that mean something to you have
an impact build your business build your
audience again you have an opportunity
here that if you follow those things
those those bits of wisdom across this
entire series you will be able to do
better than your competition who has
more skills more resources more talent
than you because you understand the
algorithm better and you have a window
of opportunity that you need to go in
and jump through it's gonna close and
you might look back and kick yourself to
say I should have gone harder when I had
the chance now is your chance you got
the chance do it stop wasting time so
come with excuses stop telling yourself
why you can't do something stop looking
for the nose and instead just find the
one reason why it will work out why you
can't do it get some momentum building
build it up I want to see some amazing
belief nation YouTube channels
conquering the world having a huge
impact that's why I made these videos so
show me that they count and that they
mean something that would mean the world
to me thank you guys again you know what
I'm gonna say I believe in you
oh but continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love guys I'll see you soon
what one singles one will this volume
you have the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details